penthouse you need to wait your turn
relax it's not a holdup it just sounds
from please how would I sign it I don't
know
slowly I I watched this movie and I was
like this is exactly what every makes
should be because it's like a cover
version it's not a direct correlation to
the other one this is like a reason to
make this movie so what movie from your
previous filmography do you think would
make for a great remake in that same
style Wow Wow
thank you for 2 hours on that I did a
picture called ride-along and very funny
very very funny
and I think I think we could redo that
again hmm I think there was a lot of
room for improvement on your version I'd
ride along I do
I do remember doing the same I do it you
know we're you in that movie I'm good
you got you got a break if I could do
one it would be me and trombone if I can
do anything was that uh was that you in
trombone comes that Oh Trumbo got it I
love those glasses I loved I loved
seeing you in a bathtub that's a
communist horn blaring piano
typing in the bathtub is my favorite
yeah that's one of the one of the most
honestly one of the most part of the
scenes I've ever done was the whole
thing with a typewriter right because
it's like who uses those anymore then in
between I was like pianos you do a
sketch that you were playing my
character again is that were you talking
about like I know some of the movie I
did that's a different conversation
what's ice cube really like what's ice
cube really like yeah when you wrote
along with him yeah he's my brother and
every sense of the word I don't call him
ice cube would you call me mr. cube it
works yeah yeah it's a sign of
fact yeah absolutely coming from the the
ghetto yeah streets as we do right well
I mean that suit screams I'm from the
streets yeah it does
yeah I know we from I know you back and
then the group that he originated and W
a very sick as you be nwb not a mwb mine
no the group and a BB ya BB thought it
was a wasn't a WB very sick but very
successful airline yeah yeah WB make
sure your seats are full upright
position
hey you know exits are located here in
here [ __ ] I want to be on that
airline so plane Slayer stuff with you
do back sir yeah to what what's in the
bags were not that's a common ground
that's what this movies about huh
it's about finding something that you
relate to in someone else that you're
where you never expected it okay how did
that come into play for you guys in real
life um good question first of all I
think that the tug of war of this
relationship is so amazing because of
how defined it is you know where these
two men are coming from two completely
different sides of the spectrum and
accidentally find themselves in a
position to grow from a relationship
perspective I can relate to it because
there's so many people that I can call
friends now that I never saw myself
getting along with in my life Ryan being
one of them because of the because of
the age difference
he's mines old you know he's an old guy
and and I'm not talking like kind of old
I'm talking like [ __ ] old so when you
have the opportunity to to really spend
time with old old people you know they
some of them some of them aren't alert
there's those there's old people that
could you just stop talking and change
my diapers but I found myself really not
just going to like mine but respecting
and there was a high level of admiration
for the way that he approached his craft
and the relationship that we built on
set it's one that lasted to where I can
say hey this guy is a good guy he's a
friend but this is something that you
don't see happening these are moments
that are created that you had to take
advantage of when they're given so that
would be a common ground of how can
relate to the story right yeah the to
the characters are different we're
different
mm-hm and the characters didn't know
that they would have this relationship
we didn't know that we would have a
relationship during the movie after the
movie and it is it is really sweet and
and gentle actually it is just to see
two grown men straight men who are
having a relationship that's very loving
right and that's unusual to see that you
know in a film and it leaves the
audience with a feeling of joy and hope
and I think we can use some of that in
our society that's the thing and I kind
of came away from it really feeling like
you guys are for realsies friends MNR we
are for realsies
yeah great Rosy's doesn't say that yeah
we are wait what happened
he's something in his eye it's something
you have something yeah there's
something going on here that moment yeah
but you're they're friends though
there's only been I've only I've only
been friends with one other older white
guy really
there's only been one other older white
guy what I mean who wasn't alan arkin me
and alan arkin hit it off
I mean if you're gonna be friends with
an old white guy but I can sit up here
say you know Brian made it tough you
know I don't know who my my old white
guy is sure you do there's only room for
a one old there's only you can only have
one old white guy anyway so I guess it's
Alan but uh you know this is it's good
to know that I got a that I got a an
option
my Geryon give me a hell and fall out
everybody well I don't need you anyway I
got Brian you have more than one okay I
got it change it Michael B Jordan um
there's a man there's a man right there
that's a man talk about cut that dude is
cut yet deeper than you know all right
all right you know that hurts me hey you
know that hurts me don't break out my
security
don't talk about my muscles
you